toujours en compagnie de Gérard Larcher
ici à Paris juste à quelques pas du
Sénat on va quitter le débat du mariage
pour tous on va évoquer cette question
des municipales également vous êtes
maire de Rambouillet est-ce que vous
allez vous présenter pour un nouveau
mandat en mars prochain d'abord le
Conseil des ministresieur a examiné et
propose un texte sur ce qu'ils appellent
le cumul des mandats je dois vous dire
je suis en totale des accords avec ce
texte non pas du tout que je ne pense
pas qu'une se pose pas des questions
notamment en termes de conflits
d'intérêt d'ailleurs comme président du
Sénat j'avais confié à la commission des
lois à l'époque et un rapporteur un
président
UMP un rapporteur socialiste le soin de
nous faire des propositions sur les
conflits d'intérêt mais je pense qu'il
est utile pour la République que un
parlementaire puisse exercer un mandat
exécutif local et un seul et d'ailleurs
depuis 30 ans je suis maire de
Rambouillet depuis plus de 26 ans j'ai
été élu parlementaire je pense avoir pu
exercer ces deux production j'allais
dire dans le respect de chacune des
fonctions et au contraire avoir enrichi
de mon expérience des Luc local
l'exercice de ma fonction nationale et
inversement donc je combattrai ce texte
s'il devient ce texte la loi de la
République en République en démocrate et
bien je verrai le moment venu la
décision que je prendrais mais je ne la
prendrai qu'une fois la loi votée
moi je suis profondément attaché au
mandat local
ça fait cinq mandats je suis aussi
profondément attaché au Sénat que j'ai
eu l'honneur de présider et je ne
prendrai ma décision qu'une fois le
texte connu parce que je pense qu'ici il
y a aucune majorité qui a une
extraordinaire hypocrisie car la
majorité des sénateurs socialistes
partage mon sentiment la quasi-totalité
des Radicaux de Gauche partage mon
sentiment et donc il va bien falloir un
moment
je parlais tout à l'heure de discrédit
de la parole politique et bien c'est le
moment où la parole politique doit avoir
le courage de dire les choses moi je
suis favorable à l'exercice d'amende à
parlementaire et d'Amanda exécutif local
et j'allais dire je l'assume devant tous
mes concitoyens j'ai d'ailleurs écrit il
y a pas longtemps au rambolique mais ça
peut être un signe aussi pour eux de
morale en politique d'éviter le moral
elle est bien ailleurs elle est dans
l'étiquette qu'est-ce qu'il y aurait dit
moral à heithmer et parlementaire
dites-moi alors vous évoquez ces mandats
mais le Parisien il y a quelques
semaines à faire un classement des des
élites politiques qui cumulent plus
de Lyon à Millau 400 000 habitants et
moi 27000 habitants c'est beaucoup
d'honneur pour Rambouillet vous étiez
deuxièmement de ce classement trois
mandats
Lyon Dijon et Rambouillet beaucoup
d'honneur pour embouiller mais à la
limite j'assume tout ça puisque moi la
différence de je déclare tout
je ne n'accepte pas que on soit sur la
valeur de l'éthique sur l'affaire de
l'exercice de demanda on peut exercer un
seul mandat ne pas respecter l'éthique
je voudrais l'évoquer aucune histoire
récente et puis on peut exercer deux
mandats
un local un national et j'allais dire
être attaché à l'éthique si elle trouve
que c'est une espèce d'hypocrisie et
face à l'hypocrisie faut dire la vérité
plus globalement sur les municipales
concernant le département des Yvelines
départements qui est en creux à droite
est-ce que la droite peut aussi
progresser encore quand on voit par
exemple sur des législatives partielles
le Front National qui se retrouve sur
des seconds tours avec l'UMP qui éclipse
le Parti socialiste ça peut coûter être
annonciateur de ce qui va se passer dans
les mêmes
majorité
d'élus que vous classez à droite ce que
je classe au centre à droite chez les
gaullistes beaucoup de divers droites
aussi beaucoup de municipalités où il y
a des gens de sensibilité
complémentaires ça n'est pas aussi
binaire qu'on veut bien naturellement
pour un certain nombre de villes nous
avons l'objectif de tenter de les
conquérir et je pense que l'ambiance au
printemps prochain pourrait être
favorable un mot sur Valérie Pécresse
parce que c'est la chef de fil dans le
département de l'UMP elle se présente
pas encore en tout cas officiellement
aux municipales vous aimeriez qu'elle
soit candidate dans une des communes
régionales et parlementaire je vous
renvoie aux mots qu'on a eu elle exerce
deux mandats les exerce bien elle est le
chef de fil de l'opposition conseiller
régional et j'espère que elle pourra
avec d'autres permettre aux conseils
régional j'allais dire de connaître
enfin l'alternance merci Gérard Larcher
de nous avoir reçu ici on vous laisse
poursuivre ses débats autour du mariage
pour tous on l'a bien sûr entendu avec
vous et on le sait le climat est
particulièrement tendu et puis on se
retrouve pour la suite du 7 8 en plateau
à Guyancourt cette fois-ci